tonight in Boston Prince William Will
award this year's earthshot prize
created to encourage those trying to
fight climate change and protect the
environment The Prince and the Princess
of Wales visited a climate change
incubator just outside Boston yesterday
senior National Environmental
correspondent Ben Tracy also went along
and joins us now to bring us up to date
on that story Ben good morning to you
Gail good morning this is called Green
Town Labs it's the largest climate Tech
incubator in all of North America and
the prince and princess came here to
meet with some climate entrepreneurs
which is exactly the kind of thing that
the earshot prize is designed to
highlight we visited an Innovative
company in Chicago that is the only U.S
finalist for tonight's big Awards
[Music]
when the fast fashion brand Zara debuted
this little black dress this past summer
it was a pretty big deal the first party
dress made from pollution we convert
pollution into the products you use
every day so from trash to Treasures
yeah Jennifer Holmgren is CEO of lands
attack it turns Planet warming carbon
pollution into everything from those
party dresses to plastic bottles
Lululemon gym shorts household cleaning
products and even jet fuel that powered
a recent Virgin Atlantic flight from
Orlando to London we've done it at
commercial scale and there are real
products out there so it's real it's
it's it's not science fiction we've made
it work the company currently has three
facilities attached to Steel plants in
China that capture carbon emissions
before they're released in the
atmosphere and converts them into
ethanol the building blocks of countless
products
so that carbon pollution would come into
the reactors that you see there she
showed us how it works at their
demonstration lab in Chicago these
monitors were wearing detect carbon
monoxide leaks it kind of looks like
some sort of Margarita in a blender back
there those are microbes eating carbon
dioxide that's right so actually the
reason you see all the bubbling is
because the carbon dioxide is being
bubbled through the reactor and the
microbe eats it and makes ethanol
that's it it seems so simple it is
actually it's also expensive each
facility costs about 100 million dollars
and can take years to build but lands
attack hopes the technology could
eventually cut Global carbon emissions
by 10 percent and help clean up often
toxic air in countries such as China in
India a lot of people across the world
don't see a blue sky at all our dream is
that someday every child will draw the
sky with a blue crayon the technology
can also be used to make products from
the carbon found in landfills which
could make the things we now throw away
infinitely recyclable we believe in a
future where there is no such thing as
pollution or waste that is always going
to be your next raw material so this
really could be an endless loop that's
the idea
it's pretty cool stuff and she says
she's grateful to the Royals for using
their platform to give people some hope
about what could be done to combat
climate change now here in Boston today
we're going to see the prince The
Princess and the president President
Biden is coming to town for a fundraiser
and the White House says he will greet
the Royals Tony
all right it's big day there in Boston
and some pretty big technological
breakthroughs as well Ben thank you very
much